. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO. Vielen Dank an Max für dieses fantastische Intro. Es war grossartig, ein Traum. Max vielleicht auch, man weiß es nicht genau. Man weiß es schon genau. Er hätte dabei geschrieben, wenn es Max ist. In Klammern Englisch ausgesprochen. Es ist ein klassischer Max. Ja, wir sind zurück, es war eine harte Zeit, wir haben viel erlebt, es ist viel passiert. Wir waren eine Woche weg, Florentin. Was hast du in dieser Woche erlebt, dass du dir so groß ausholst? Urlaub. Ich war schön im Urlaub, ich habe schöne Birkenstockfüsse, ich war viel in der Sonne. Man muss aber auch sagen, wir haben euch ein bisschen verarscht, ehrlich gesagt. Wir haben nämlich vor zwei Wochen zwei Folgen aufgenommen, direkt. Und nicht vor drei Wochen haben wir zwei Folgen aufgenommen. Das heißt, wir haben uns zwei Wochen nicht gesehen. Ja. Das hört man auch ein bisschen, weil wir freuen uns wieder aufeinander. Wir haben wieder Spaß am Sprechen. Wir müssen aber auch ein bisschen warm werden irgendwie. Müssen aber auch wieder ein bisschen, das kennt man übrigens, es gibt halt Freunde und Freunde. Freunde, die man lange nicht gesehen hat und mit denen man sofort wieder so spricht, wie man spricht. Und dann gibt es halt die, die man im weitesten Sinne als Freunde bezeichnet, die man dann dabei spricht und man muss erst wieder warm werden miteinander. Man muss erst mal wieder ein bisschen so eine Grundunannehmlichkeiten, so unangenehme Momente überstehen erstmal, um dann wieder in den alten Flow zurückzukommen. Es gibt aber auch so asynchrone Freundschaften, wo man dann sich trifft und dann fängt ja einer an mit und wie ist die Arbeit so und man denkt sich so, wir müssen keinen Smalltalk machen, also passt schon. Also man ist schon selber in dem Freundschaftsmodus, aber der andere fühlt es nötig, nochmal zu sagen so, ah und, und jetzt Mutter immer noch tot und so. Nee, nee, lass uns direkt einfach direkt zu. Und man denkt auch sofort, ja, okay, ich habe diese Freundschaft offensichtlich falsch eingeschätzt. Weil du bist dann gerade in dem Beispiel besser mit ihm befreundet als er mit dir. Ja, das gibt es aber oft. Gibt es überhaupt eine Freundschaft, die gleichwertig ist? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich bin auf jeden Fall der Meinung, dass ich mit Leuten schlechter befreundet bin, als Leute mit mir befreundet sind.
Ich krieg oft gespiegelt, dass man, auch bei Instagram kann man neuerdings oben erkennen, dass man manchmal in engen Freundelisten ist.
Ich bin bei vielen in einer engen Freundeliste, wo ich sagen würde, hm, sind wir enge Freunde?
Ich weiß nicht mal, ob du einen zweiten Vornamen hast oder ob du Geschwister hast.
Lass uns erstmal über Freunde reden, bevor wir mit enge Freunden überhaupt anfangen, weil das ist ja schon der dritte Kreis. Wir sind drei übersprungen. Bekannte, Freunde, enge Freunde. Ja, Beziehung. Und dann wird es auch schwierig. Ich bin in drei Beziehungen und fünf enge Freunde und Sachen, wo ich dachte, das kann nicht sein. Aber für mich sind diese Instagram-Stories für enge Freunde immer so ein bisschen so, also nicht verrucht oder versaut, aber so ein bisschen intim angehaucht.
Also mal so irgendwie kein Angesicht, hängt halt mal einen Hoden aus der Boxershorts raus.
Hat man erst nach der Story gemerkt, dachte sich, der Gag ist geil, naja, mache ich für enge Freunde.
Der Gag ist sogar richtig geil.
Ja, der ist zu gut.
Geil für diesen Gag.
Aber zumindest hört Quotenmeter die eh nicht mit.
So, dann kannst du zumindest den Shitstorm vermeiden. Du hast eine Menge Shitstorms bekommen in der letzten Woche, lass uns mal da anfangen. Du warst in Bayreuth, viele haben direkt, sag ich mal, die Anti-Wagner-Keule auf dich übergezogen. Ehrlich jetzt? Ganz kurz, warum kriegst du, ich krieg von diesen Shitstorms immer nicht mit, hältst du so einen Shitstorm-Regenschirm über mich oder was? Ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, ich bin so ein bisschen wie deine Mutter beim Elternabend. Ich kriege immer alles ab, was eigentlich zu dir kommt, weil ich ja auch unseren E-Mail-Account betreue. Das heißt, du kriegst das alles gar nicht mit. Aber kannst du mir das mal bitte weiterleiten? Ich behüte dich ja davor. Warum? Ich will nicht, dass du eingegriffen wirst. Du bist mein Shitstorm-Schirm, mein SS. Ja, du bist mein SS. Da habe ich wenigstens fünf Mails rein. Ich versuche so ein bisschen die schützende Hand über dich zu halten und dann immer so, ah, Bayreuth, Wagner, Antisemit und ich antworte immer ... Kann es sein, dass du mir aktiv nur Lob weiterleidest? Klar, natürlich. Ehrlich jetzt? Ja. Ich möchte aber auch den knallharten Leute. Nein, willst du nicht. Ich will die Stefan Schwiers, wie hießen die, die mir knallhart sagen, was los ist. Habe ich echt viele Gegenwind bekommen wegen Wagner? Ein bisschen Gegenwind, ja. Und natürlich auch von wegen, ah, so viel Geld, bla, irgendwie. Es hat gar nicht viel gekostet. Ist Stefan in der High Society angekommen und so. Das Problem ist halt, viele von unseren Hörern sind auch sehr ironisch. Und das kann man nicht merken, wenn man eine Mail kriegt. Deswegen denke ich mir so, bevor ich jetzt ein großes Missverständnis aufmache. Ich muss sagen, diesesSide-Ding, das denkt man jetzt irgendwie, denkt man das von mir, weil ich jetzt eine Netflix-Serie geschrieben habe offensichtlich und am Wochenende habe ich Freunde besucht in Berlin und war auf einem Boot und ich habe so viele, da habe ich ungefiltert den Shitstorm bekommen, was ich nicht gewohnt bin, weil du mich davor beschützt.
Auf Instagram kann ich dich nicht schützen.
Das kennt man ja von Kindern, die die ganze Zeit drinnen waren in der Wohnung, weil ihre Eltern sie beschützen wollen.
Und dann gehen die mal raus und haben direkt eine Allergie.
Und so ist es bei uns ein bisschen so.
Du warst mich vor Shitstorm, da bin ich ja in der echten Welt da draußen alleine.
Auf dem Boot.
Auf dem Boot. Und dann krieg ich plötzlich sehr viel Shitstorm ab und bin das gar nicht gewohnt und ist man kurz davor, in so einer Depression zu verfallen.
Und da habe ich auch sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen wie Money Stephan, wow Netflix Money, wow, Netflix Money, wow, jetzt hat er auf dem Boot, jetzt hat er komplett die Bodenhaftung verloren und so weiter, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, weil ich auf dem Wasser war. Aber ja, das ist nur zu sagen, nein, das war nicht mein Boot, das war das Boot von einem Freund oder engen Freund, ich weiß es nicht, welche Listen ich da jetzt einordnen soll, der dieses Boot sehr günstig bekommen hat und in Berlin ein armer Student ist. Und der hat sich immer was gegönnt. Nur weil der jetzt weinst, die mit Nachnamen heisst, muss man jetzt auch nicht direkt eine Verbindung ziehen. Von Habsburg. Da muss man jetzt auch sagen, muss man da jetzt groß sauber, was ist auf dem Bildschirm gerade so wichtig? Du starrst auf dem Bildschirm, das ist das. Was? Ich zähle die Minuten. Guckst du auf die Uhrzeit, was ist los? Willst du wieder in Urlaub? Nein, aber du warst auf dem Boot und ich gönnst dir, weil du sahst sehr entspannt aus. Und ich dachte mir, endlich kann der mal ein bisschen entspannen. Du, das ist eine neue Phase hat begonnen. Du siehst auch, ich habe einen neuen Smoothie dabei, ich war gerade noch schön, haben wir mir einen Saft gekauft. Das ist ein schmolzenes Eis, das ist kein Smoothie. Ja, gut. Sieht, die Hörörer jetzt nicht gesehen. Aber der Lifestyle-Stefan hat begonnen, der, der immer sagt, ich bin jetzt 25 geworden, vielen Dank für deine Geburtstagsklückwünsche nochmal im Übrigen und ich wünsche mir, ich möchte einfach jetzt langsam, habe ich das Prinzip der Work-Life-Balance für mich entdeckt, ich muss einfach ein bisschen mehr, ich muss ein bisschen mehr leben. Ich muss mal rauskommen.
Ich gehe jetzt abends weg,
ich trinke Säfte, ich gehe auf Boote, Böte.
Du gehst abends weg. Wo gehst du hin?
Mal raus. Einfach raus. Ganz kurz raus.
Dann wieder rein. Schön zum Briefkasten, nochmal zur
Packstation. Briefkasten, Mülleimer,
Pfannflaschen, rein.
Ich habe eine Packstation bei mir in der Nähe
und die ist, sag ich mal, an einer U-Bahn-Haltestelle
und da treiben sich Kriminelle rum. So. Sagen wir es so, wie es ist. Sagen wir es einfach so, wie es ist. Und deswegen gehe ich da immerhin ohne Geld. Ich habe immer nur meine Karte dabei und habe den Code im Kopf. Und dein Paket. Ach so was. Und das Paket hole ich dann ja ab. Du lässt es dir da hinschicken. Genau, ich lasse es in die Parkstation schicken. Und dann denke ich mir immer, ich gehe da hin und lasse es mir raus und habe dann das Buch. Ich habe jetzt noch mal ein Buch über die Schlacht von Verdard bestellt und dann stelle ich mir mal vor, wie ich auf dem Weg von der Packstation nach Hause überfallen werde und ich einfach nur dieses eine Buch über die Schlacht von Verdard aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg habe und er so, ja, gib mir dein Geld. Magst du den Ersten Weltkrieg? Hast du Bock, ein bisschen Facts auszutauschen über Verdard? Es funktioniert nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt, mit diesem ...
Ob das überhaupt passiert Leuten,
so dieses Bedrohtwerden und dann Geldübergabe,
oder ob das einfach ein Filmding ist, was nie stattfindet.
Ich weiß auch nicht, in Deutschland, glaube ich, sind wir davor einigermassen gefeit.
Kommt vielleicht auch auf Anwo, ne?
Also ich glaube, da gibt's bestimmt ... Was ist jetzt passiert?
Ich hab mir gerade Kaffee über mein Skyshirt gegossen,
und ich hab hiernach gleich eine Wohnungsbesichtigung. Ja, jetzt kommt wieder Netflix Money. Oh, Stefan, die nächste Loft. Oh mein Gott, nein. Wird es eine Loft? Ja, es ist ein Riesen-Riesen-Loft. Aber jetzt habe ich gerade Kaffee auf mein Shirt gegossen. Was ist das für ein erster Eindruck dann? Dreh es um. Ja, und das ist der schlechte Eindruck. So ist zumindest, er konnte sich Kaffee leisten, war es dann komischerweise, aber das hat doch jetzt aus, ich verschütte Dinge. Stefan, es gibt einen eigenen Instagram-Account. Den sieht der Makler ja nicht. Wirklich, wenn man deinen Namen googelt, das erste, was man findet, ist Stefan Titzes-Bitz. Da muss man mal mit Google reden, auch habe ich ja schon oft überlegt. Wenn man meinen Namen googelt, ist man erstmal Hopfeln und Malz verloren. Ja gut, aber ich meine besser als die ganzen anderen Accounts, die es noch so gibt über dich. Das stimmt. Sexy, sexy Bear 93. Aber hast du, lügst du bei der Wohnungsbesichtigung? Natürlich, aber das machen ja auch alle. Das machen ja auch alle. Was sind so deine Top-3-Standard-Lügen? Platz Nummer drei? Ich bin festangestellt. Ja, Platz Nummer zwei? Ich habe ein höheres Einkommen als XXX. Und Platz Nummer eins? Ich verschütte nie Dinge. Okay, das haben Sie jetzt schon dreimal erwähnt. Nee, ich verschütte keine Dinge. Die wollen nicht. Ihr habt Ihre Blicke gesehen. Ein ausgefallenes Muster hat Ihr T-Shirt, muss man sagen. Es ist ja sehr modisch. Ja, das war ein sehr teures Shirt. Aus, das habe importieren lassen, weil... Diese braunen Flecken überall, ich finde das ist sehr ansprechend. Genau, genau. Das ist so eine Art Camouflage-Look, oder? Ja, ja, genau, das trägt man gerade so, und das ist ganz toll. Haben Sie was zu trinken, vielleicht? Ja, klar, natürlich ein Glas Wasser. Ach, das ist auch... Na, dankeschön. Nee, das ist ein ganz neuer Look, und, oh, ups. Oh, huch. Nee, nee, das ist ja ...
Das ist ja kein Wet-T-Shirt-Contest hier.
Man muss manchmal ein bisschen was aufs T-Shirt machen.
Oh, kann ich Ihnen gleich noch ein Glas geben?
Nee, nee, alles gut, lieber nicht, lieber nicht, lieber nicht, lieber nicht.
Ist ein Einstellplatz mit dabei, oder?
Ja, eins tatsächlich, aber das ist sehr aufwendige Elektronik, sag ich mal.
Also da müsste man aufpassen mit Flüssigkeiten.
Ja, nee, klar, das kann ich.
Ups, da lauter.
Ja, uch, uch, die Vase. Ach, das ist jetzt natürlich unglücklich. Oh nein, weil ich helfe Ihnen auf mit dem Auf... Sie stehen ein bisschen nah am Aquarium, müssen jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen. Oh, wo ist ein Aquarium? Ups, wo ist ein Aquarium? Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ohif? Ich glaube ja. Kann man eigentlich, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, Fische auf dem Boden, kann man die einfach runterschlucken? Übergangsweise. Oh, hast du die neue Serie Euphoria geschaut? Nein. Nur zu empfehlen, eine fantastische Serie. Drogen? Neue, geht ja viel nur um Drogen. Ja. Um Jugendliche, die im Internet anfangen, Drogen zu verkaufen. Ganz fantastische Serie. Nee, es geht nur um Jugendliche, die Drogen nehmen primär. Und das ist eine tolle Serie auf HBO, unbedingt zu empfehlen, kann man da auch auf Sky gucken, bin mir nicht sicher, oder illegal runterladen, jedenfalls. Aber ganz kurz, bevor du weitermachst, ist das nicht die perfekte Möglichkeit für einen Crossover? Ja. Staffel zwei Euphoria, so, wo kriegen wir unsere Drogen her? Und dann kommt dieser lockige Typ an und gibt ihnen Drogen. Ich hab mir schon öfter überlegt. Perfekt. Ich war eh für so einen Crossover. Zumindest wäre ich für so einen deutschen Netflix-Crossover, dass unsere Charaktere irgendwann durch so ein Zeitloch gehen und bei Dark rauskommen. Ja, aber ich mein, könnt ihr nicht mal so in Staffel zwei, wo der bestätigt, How to Sell Drugs Online Fast, mal so einMason, da ist dieser Typ, der hat dieses blaue Meth, der nimmt uns den ganzen Markt weg. Zwinker, zwinker und nächste Szene. Sowas?
Oh, Funfact, wir wollten in dem Zimmer des Protagonisten, wollten wir ein Breaking Bad Poster aufhängen. Ah ja. Weil, ich meine, die Serie ist ja sehr transparent damit, in welcher Zeit erlebt und dass es eine sehr popkulturaffine Charaktere sind und so weiter.
Die wissen ja genau, das ist eigentlich wie ein Zombiefilm, in dem die Charaktere wissen, dass Zombies existieren.
Und so weiß er ja auch, dass Serien mit Breaking Bad existieren.
Deswegen fanden wir es halt immer lustig, wenn ein Breaking Bad-Poster bei ihm im Zimmer hängt.
Nur leider hat Breaking Bad das nicht erlaubt, weil sie nicht mit einer Serie in Verbindung gebracht werden wollen, wo es um Drogen geht.
Das war die Begründung, die Mail-Begründung, die kam. Ich muss bis heute lachen darüber. Ja, aber wer erlaubt das? Also, aber ist es dann... Naja, das sind dann so Lizenzleute, PR-Dudes, meistens von den Produktionsfirmen etc., wo die Lizenzen halt liegen, beziehungsweise von den Studios. Aber die wollen nicht mit Drogen in Verbindung gebracht werden. Wo ich kurz nachfragen wollte und sage, ja, ihr seid schon mit Drogen in Verbindung gebracht. Habt ihr die Serie mal gesehen? Jetzt habt ihr einen Lost-Poster einfach. Jetzt haben wir das. Weil er ist ja auch so ein bisschen lost. Also in seiner... Ja, man muss auch über diese Metapher nachdenken. Muss man auch machen. Ne, Euphoria ist ganz toll und da gab es eine Fred-Party und dann war eine, so diese Challenges für diese neuen Studenten,
ein Wasserglas zu trinken mit einem Goldfisch drin.
Mit einem lebenden Goldfisch.
Und dann trinken die das weg.
Und dann ist der Goldfisch in dir drin.
Wo auch echt die Frage, finde ich, nicht so uninteressant ist, ob der dann lebt
noch weiter. Ja, so Magensäfte
wird wahrscheinlich farblich. Ist schon krass, aber wenn du vorher viel trinkst?
Aber endet der dann in der Blase?
Wann wird der Wasserteil und der Feste eigentlich getrennt?
Keine Ahnung.
Wo ist die Mülltrennung, wo findet die statt im Körper?
Mich wundert, dass eh das so gut klappt,
dass man nicht einfach mal, sag ich mal, aufs Klo geht
und es ist so falsch rum.
Ja, ja.
Und man sich denkt, ach, Körper, was war da los?
Das berühmte Lied, kann man mit dem Pipimann auch A auch A-A machen? Oder kann man mit dem Pipi-Mann auch A-A machen? Auch von Wagner oder was? Nee, es ist von Strauss. Ich weiß, es ist so ein Kinderli, es ging damals, als ich elf war, ging das viral. Das war so das erste virale Video, was ich gesehen habe. Und ich und ich fand das natürlich als Elfrierech, fand das natürlich unglaublich lustig.
Wahnsinn.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, wie der Text ging. Ich bin ja nicht so textsicher. Ich gucke mal kurz nach.
Aber das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es funktioniert mit der Mülltrende im Körper.
Ich dachte, du überbrückst jetzt, aber wir ziehen uns jetzt durch.
Ich mag das Geräusch von Laptop-Tippen, ich finde das immer sehr berührend.
Das ist so laut bei mir, dass Leute in der Bahn immer fragen, ob ich es vielleicht ausmachen könnte mit dem Tastenton.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Wessen Idee war das eigentlich? Kann man mit dem Pipi-Mann auch A-A machen, oder ist er dafür noch zu klein? Darf man mit dem Popo auch mal Pipi machen, oder kommt der gleiche Polizei? Kommt gleich die Polizei. Alles klar. Gut, danke, wunderbar, das war's mit dem Grimme-Preis. Vielen Dank an der Stelle an Stefan T. Dankeschön. Lass mich kriegen wir einen Grimme-Preis. Nein, glaube ich nicht. Nee, machen die Fallschirmfolge. Ich glaube, die Fallschirmfolge könnte noch was werden. Ich war im Supermars! Da sind die Schlangen lang! Den, den, den, den, den, den! Abspann. Genau, du warst im Urlaub. Und da wollte ich mal nachfragen, wie es denn war. Denn du warst jedes Jahr, warst du Campen und hast Pokémon gespielt. Ja, wie jedes Jahr. Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt das 15. Jahr oder so, sind wir jetzt jedes Jahr Campen. Hat immer großen Spaß, ist immer sehr entspannt, ist wie so eine kleine Zeitkapsel, wo man nochmal so 15 Jahre alt sein darf. Und merkt, dass es mit 25 doch ganz geil ist. Ja, es stimmt schon, es stimmt schon. Und wir werden auch immer noch als die Jugendlichen bezeichnet, wenn wir da am Campingplatz ankommen. Ah, die Jugendlichen. Von Leuten, die 18 sind. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals geupdatet wird. Und wir kennen, also das ist so ein kleines bayerisches Dorf. Und wir kennen die Leute da mittlerweile so gut, dass wir auch, da gibt es einen Supermarkt, auf den wir angewiesen sind. Und wir haben auch die Nummer des Besitzers des Supermarkts und so. Und wir kennen die Leute mittlerweile so gut, dass wir auch, da gibt es einen Supermarkt halt, auf den wir angewiesen sind.
Und wir haben auch die Nummer des Besitzers des Supermarkts und so. Und wir hatten ein Problem, weil wir am Samstag angekommen sind und wir konnten nicht mehr einkaufen und haben am Sonntag den Edeka-Besitzer angerufen und gefragt, können wir heute auch einkaufen bei Ihnen? Und er so, ja, aber es kommt so mehr. Und dann hat er uns am Sonntag den Edeka aufgesperrt. Nein. Und ich war alleine in einem stockdunklen Edeka. Echt, dunkel? Stockdunkel, wo alles dunkel war. Und auch über diese Kühlschränke, also diese Kühlauslagen, wo die Wurst und so drin liegt, da waren dann auch so Schalen drüber und so. Es war wie so ein Winterschlaf-Supermarkt, so wie man es sonst noch nie kennt. Die gehen über Nacht im Winterschlaf. Das ist total abgefahren. Und dann durfte ich mir da Sachen rausnehmen und war da so ganz ein Kindheitstraum, so mal so übernachten in einem Supermarkt. Ja, ja. Oder übernachten in einem McDonalds. Oder im Ikea, dachte ich immer. Grossartig. Und dann durfte ich mir da Sachen nehmen und da das Kassensystem nicht funktioniert hat, wurde das alles aufgeschrieben und ich habe es am nächsten Tag bezahlt. Aber das ist schon so, die kennen uns so gut und die freuen sich schon das ganze Jahr darauf, dass wir kommen, weil das ist so das Highlight in dem Dorf, dass die acht Jugendlichen kommen. Ihr seid das Highlight, aber deine Prominentspiele haben keine Rolle, ne? Einfach nur, dass du existierst. Aber es ist auch mal schön, also das ist doch toll, dass man mag dich für das, was du bist. Total, ja, man mag mich dafür, dass ich seit jedes Jahr da hinkomme, ja. Und es ist großartig. Aber gut, dass du da so einen andersartigen Prominentenstatus hast.
Einfach weil du jedes Jahr da bist.
Du hast dir diese Karriere gewissermaßen anders aufgebaut.
Aber auch genauso wie deine andere. Das finde ich
toll. Ja, es ist grossartig. Ich habe Pokémon
wieder durchgespielt. Komplett durch.
Nur mit Pummelow. Hat es geklappt. Und hat sehr gut geklappt.
Also ich glaube, Pummelow ist eines der besten Pokémon,
um diese Chalice zu machen, weil es so viele
verschiedene Attacken lernen kann.
Du kannst den Blubstrahl, Donnerblitz, Psychokinese. Ist Pummelup, gehört das nicht so klasse normal? Richtig, aber man kann viele andere Sachen ihm lernen, oder ihr lernen, deswegen ist es sehr effizient. Ich glaube, es ist fast das einfachste Pokémon, um diese Ein-Pokémon-Challenge zu machen. In welchem Alter lernen Pokémon, dass sie zur Gattung normal gehören? Es ist deprimierend. Und sie sind halt mega enttäuscht. Und es gibt ja dann auch immer so die Trainer so, ich bin der Vogelfänger und ich bin der Elektromeister. Ich bin ganz normal. Und ich bin stinknormal, ich habe normale Pokémon. Ich bin stinknormal, mein Name ist Norman. Norman Normalo. Ich bin einfach normal. Und es ist ... Da haben wir so einen Typ mit Jeans und Shirt. Ja. Und alle haben so dieser Ranger mit dem Netz, wo er die Schmetterlinge mitfängt, der Insekten-Typ mit diesem Entdeckungshut. Ja. Dieser typische Ich-gehe-auf-Entdeckung-Hut. Ja. Und dann der Normalo einfach Sneaker-Jeans, Shirt. Es sind einfach normale Zivilisten, einfach normale Passanten. Das sind ja auch so viele Fragen im Pokémon-Universum so, hat jeder Mensch Pokémon? Ja. Oder gibt es auch Leute, die einfach sagen so, ich habe nichts, so, ist das nur eine ausgewählte Gruppe an Leuten? Oder hat jeder das? Man weiß es nicht genau. Auch hier hat der Pokémon-Film versagt. Ja. Er hätte viele Fragen beantworten können, wenn du in so einem Franchise mal ein bisschen Zeit hast, 90 Minuten Zeit hast, was zu erklären. Vor allem die Größenverhältnisse von Pokémon sind ja auch so ein bisschen umstritten. Es gab ja in der Anime-Serie
war ja teilweise Turtalk so gross
wie ein Hochhaus. Ja, stimmt.
Und aber manchmal auch wieder so gross
einfach wie ein Erweiterer. Tentoxa hat eine Stadt terrorisiert.
Ja. Dieser Schwarm aus Tentoxa.
Wieso kriegt der Weltenartig? Und auf den
Pokémon-Karten stand ja die Körpergrösse
drauf. Ich glaube, da war Turtalk so 1,70
oder 1,80 oder so. Deutlich
kleiner als ich. Also er ging mir bis zur Brust. Ja, es war so ein normaler 15-Jähriger, einfach normal gross. Und man sich denkt, warum? Als 15-Jähriger denkst du, wow, ist der gross Turtog. Warum ist der so klein? Aber als Erwachsener denkst du, hm, ein grosser Hund. Es ist ganz merkwürdig. Und das war wahrscheinlich auch für den Pokémon-Film eine Herausforderung, zu sagen, wie gross. Und am Ende hat man gesagt, ja, wie so ein Pool halt, oder? Alle ganz, ganz klein. Ja. Für die Spielzeugindustrie wahrscheinlich nicht so trivial, wie gross die dann sind. Ja gut, aber die müssen ja auch nicht immer im Verhältnis groß sein, ne? Also bei den Kuscheltieren ist ein Pikachu dann genauso gross wie ein Turtok, obwohl der natürlich in der Serie viel kleiner ist. Warum macht Steiff die Firma, warum machen die nicht Pokémon, aber so genau so realitätsrecht. Oder so altdeutsch, so ganz altdeutsch. Detailliert wie auch so Dinosaurier, aber halt Turtok. Ja. Das finde ich richtig cool. Vielleicht auch Lizenzprobleme. Ich glaube, alle selbliche gute Ideen sind durch Lizenzprobleme gelöst. Wo ich mir einfach auch denke, zahlt man denn immer dasselbe für eine Lizenz? Zum Beispiel, Beispiel, Achtung, Pflaster mit
Spider-Man drauf.
Lohnt es sich wirklich für einen Pflaster-Hersteller
die Lizenz von
Marvel, Spider-Man, super krass
zu kaufen für
Pflaster? Oder sagen die,
ach scheiss drauf, das sind Pflaster,
da kriegt ihr Spider-Man für fünf und Honi.
Ich weiss nicht genau.
Es kommt ein bisschen auf die Verwertung an, glaube ich.
Was bedeutet das?
Was bedeutet das? Es kommen auf die Verwertung an.
Nee, war schön.
Ich hoffe, dass wir uns noch mal treffen können demnächst.
Aber wie gesagt, ich muss morgen früh raus.
Ja, ja, ja.
Du meinst doch, du hast ...
Zahlen bitte, genau.
Nee, schön, wir können die Rechnung ruhig wiederlegen.
Nee, wir können einfach ...
Sie haben doch gesagt, dass sie noch einen Besicherungstermin gleich haben.
Wir haben gesagt, um 15 Uhr.
Nee, den habe ich abgesagt.
Warum schlucken Sie jetzt so intensiv?
Hör, nee, das ist mein normales Schluckgeräusch.
Warum Sie...
Waren wir nicht im Doom?
Nee, wir hatten eigentlich gesagt, dass ich wieder zum Sie zurückkehren möchte.
Ach so, ja.
Also läuft es nicht gut, was sind jetzt die Anzeichen?
Sie haben den gesamten Rotwein über ihr T-Shirt geschildert. Ja, ich kleckere! Da haben wir so eine Kampagne. Ja, ich kleckere! So what? Akzeptiert mich, wie ich bin! Ja, aber es stimmt schon, es ist einfach... Warum ist Kleckern so peinlich? Wahrscheinlich, weil es auch was mit Körperflüssigkeiten zu tun hat, sabbern, so wirklich frühkindliche Beziehungen. Es strahlt auch Unsicherheit aus. Und nicht der Herr, ich glaube, es ist sexy, Herr über den eigenen Körper zu sein. Sexy, ja. Es ist sexy. Aber ich glaube, wenn du, also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt so einen Dialog schreibst, wie jemand seine Liebe gesteht, dann würdest du eher, ah, der ist unsicher und verhaspelt sich und keine Ahnung und so und würde dann auch was verschütten. Das wäre dann eher, sag ich mal, wo man dann signalisiert, ah, die Liebe ist so überwältigend, dass er seinen Körper gar nicht oder sie keinen Körper überhaupt nicht mehr in der Kontrolle haben kann. Wogegen sexy, ja, stimme ich dir zu, ist Kleckern vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Richtige. Genau. Es kommt immer darauf an, auch dann, wie man damit umgeht, mit dem Kleckern auch an sich. Es gibt, man mag ja auch immer die Situation, wenn jemand irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, Nutella am Mund hat oder so, und man dann so sagt so, ey, du hast hier Nutella am Mund, und dann kommen so diese 30 Sekunden des Links, Rechts, Links, mein Links, dein Links, aber irgendwann, also wenn der andere es partout nicht hinbekommt, dann sage ich einfach, okay, ist weg, ohne dass es weg ist. Und man sagt einfach, passt schon, und er läuft den Rest des Tages durch die Welt, schaut in den Spiegel und denkt sich, was, warum sind schon wieder da? Aber einfach
der Punkt, wo man sagt, ja, du hast
das Zeitfenster überschritten, jetzt musst du
damit leben einfach. Ja, genau. Passt schon.
Es gibt so ein gewisses Intervall.
Es gibt ein Fenster und irgendwann ist das Fenster zu.
Es ist einfach zu. Irgendwann geht's nicht mehr, das stimmt schon.
Nee, ich bin dafür, dass
es dieses Fenster geben sollte, gerade ziehe ich es noch durch,
knallhart. Und wenn ich da zwei Stunden sitze.
Ja, wirklich? Bis zum letzten Schluss? Bis ich dann irgendwann meinen Daumen anlecke und es selber wegmache. Da muss man auch irgendwann all in gehen. Speichel hat einen Geruch, ne? Aber ich habe das Gefühl, man kann nur Fremdenspeichel riechen. Nee, du kannst der Mundgeruch testen, weil du kannst ja nicht dieses, was man im Film sieht, dieses in die Hand hauchen und selber einatmen, so kannst du deinen Mundgeruch nicht checken. Deinen Mundgeruch kannst du checken, indem du den Handrücken ableckst, zehn Sekunden wartest und dann dran riechst. Warum muss man zehn Sekunden warten? Damit das einzieht. Und dann bleiben die Partikel, du riechst es erst nicht und dann bleibt der Geruch, die Essenz über. Und es riecht immer ungeil, es riecht immer, man denkt immer, mach das mal. Aber warum riecht man denn seinen Speichel nicht, während man redet? Also die Nase ist ja direkt über dem Mund. Das müsste doch eigentlich auch so strafen. Ich glaube, die Nase hat so einen Spam-Filter, so einen, kenne ich schon, Spam-Filter. Zehn Sekunden warten. Ich liebe die Vorstellung, dass wie in ganz Deutschland jetzt die ganzen Podcast-Uferhörer, alle, egal wo sie sind, im Bus, in der Bahn, an der Hand lecken.
Alle so an der Hand lecken.
Und man in der S-Bahn sagt, ah, da sind Podcast-Uferhörer.
Es riecht ja immer so ein bisschen schlecht.
Ich rieche gar nichts.
Es riecht nach meiner Seife.
Ich rieche halt jetzt primär meine Hand.
Du wirst deine Zunge nicht einseifen, habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Oh, doch, nee, oh, oh.
Ja, ja, da kommt es immer durch.
Ah, das riecht so wie beim Zahnarzt, wenn die Gummihandschuhe dann so in den Mund rumrumoren und dann hält die Zahnärztin einem auch dann die Gummihandschuhe direkt unter die Nase, weil da der Mund ist und dann riecht man es. Das riecht unangenehm.
Ich mag es nicht.
Kann man da nicht was gegen machen, so das Mundgeruch, Speichel, kann das nicht weg.
Ich riecht nach dem Saft, den ich gerade trinke.
Den mag ich auch nicht. Ich habe jetzt auch angefangen, meine Zunge aktiv zu bürsten. Ich auch, ja. Irgendwann habe ich damit angefangen, weil irgendwie so, man sieht es ja immer so die Werbungen, wo hinten auf der Zahnbürste noch so ein Rubber drauf ist und man denkt sich so, keine Ahnung, was soll das. Aber tatsächlich, geswitcht hat es erst, als sich den Film The Act
of Killing, ein extrem harter
Film, da geht es um einen
indonesischen Massenmord und
wie die Täter dann dargestellt werden.
Also schaut euch den jetzt nicht einfach so ha ha ha
an, aber einer dieser Massenmörder,
der wird gezeigt in der Szene,
wo er duscht und sich währenddessen
die Zähne putzt und er
putzt sich auch immer seine Zunge und muss immer würgen. Aber er würgt wirklich zehn, zwanzig Mal und macht aber immer weiter. Wo ich meine Zuschauer an sich immer denke, Alter, was machst du falsch? Du kannst doch nicht denken, dass es richtig ist. Aber seitdem dachte ich mir... Aber wenn ich meine Zunge sauber mache, habe ich auch manchmal... Manchmal übertreibt man es. Genau. Und dann kommt die Grenze, dann kommt der Wirkereflekt. Genau. Und dann lässt man es
aber auch sein, da hinten.
Da merkt man, okay, der Körper sagt, ich bin zu tief
vorgedrungen. Richtig, aber ich dachte mir so,
ich muss einen besseren Mundgeruch
haben als ein indonesischer Massenmörder.
Also übergibst du dich
jeden Morgen. Also muss ich mir zumindest auch
die Zunge putzen. Seitdem
putze ich mir die Zunge und komme auch an diesen
Würgepunkt, wo ich mir auch denke, warum also es gibt ja so dieses Würgereflex desensibilisieren, gerade im, ich sag mal, Erwachsenenfilmbereich. Warum kann ich das nicht? Warum kriegst du das nicht hin? Ich mache das jeden Tag und ich würge jeden Morgen. Jeden Morgen. Das ist neu, du würgst jetzt jeden Morgen. Das gehört jetzt einfach zu meinem Leben dazu. Ich bin in einem Alter angekommen. Wie viel wirkst du mehr als noch vor einem Jahr? Pro Tag 100% mehr. Mehr von 0 auf 1 ist schwer. Angenommen, man hätte dir das vorher gesagt. So in einem Jahr wirst du 200.000% mehr würgen als dieses Jahr. Hättest du gesagt? Ich hätte gesagt, hör auf, lass mich in Ruhe, steig wieder ein, ich bin raus hier. Und ich hatte tatsächlich diese Vorstellung, ich war ja sehr lange sehr fett und habe immer überlegt, wie kann ich genauso viel essen, aber nicht so fett sein. Es gibt einen Trick. Das ist ein einfacher Trick. Ich, ich weiss, woraus du hinauslaust. Und dann hat mir jemand mal von Caesar erzählt und gesagt, der wurde ermordet und pass auf, irgendwie deine besten Freunde können dir in den Rücken fallen und dich erstechen. Da habe ich gesagt, pass auf, was mich viel mehr interessiert ist, wie konnte der so verdammt schlank sein? Sexy. War so sexy, wie konnte der sein, warum war der so hot? Und er hat gesagt, ah ja, das kann ich dir auch beantworten. Nichts verschüttet. Gehört zu den zwei Dingen, die ich weiß. Und zwar haben die immer so viel gegessen und dann halt den klassischen Federtrick, halt mit der Fedegauben gekitzelt, sich übergeben und dann konnten sie mehr essen. Und ich dachte mir, genial, ich esse dann halt einfach nicht mehr, sondern kotze alles aus, aber ich habe es nicht hinbekommen, mich selber zum Erbrechen zu kriegen, weil ich es so ekelhaft fand, mit den Fingern in den Mund zu stecken. Und ich fand, ich finde allein die Vorstellung, sich den Finger in den Mund zu stecken, schon so ekelhaft, dass ich davon schon wirken muss und es eigentlich skippen kann, aber ich hätte es nie hinbekommen, nie hinbekommen. Und deswegen musste ich fett bleiben. Das sollte man auch nicht machen. Nein, natürlich ist es klar, dass nicht abnehmen kann, aber... Doch, man kann damit abnehmen, aber das ist ganz, ganz furchtbar, das sollte man nicht tun. Wie, man kann damit abnehmen? Klar, ich hatte auch ein paar Schulfreunde, die magersüchtig wurden, weil die immer ihr Essen ausgekotzt haben, das ist nicht gut. Macht, don't go there, aber kann man denn von Übergewicht direkt magersüchtig werden?
Nein, es ist nicht Null oder Eins, das ist ja dann schon eine Phase und so.
Das Problem ist halt, dass dann viele Nährstoffe fehlen, weil die Leute dann meistens gar nichts mehr essen, sodass es halt krankhaft wird.
Also wenn ihr merkt, dass ihr euch bei einem schönen Essen unwohl fühlt, dann versucht mal, mit Leuten drüber zu reden.
Schreibt uns gerne auch eine Mail.
Schreibt Florentin gerne eine Mail.
Wir erzeugen mir eine Mail. Und leidet bitte nicht weiter. Leidet bitte nicht weiter direkt in den Müll. Werbung. Ah, auf den Wirke her wurde ich von einem Eichhörnchen gebissen. Florentin. Ah, das sieht böse aus. Böse aus. Ich glaube, ich muss zum Arzt. Aber ich weiß nicht, dann fragt er mich sowas wie, bist du Tetanus geimpft und so. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ja, aber Stefan, dann hast du keine TK-Safe-Funktion, der TK-App, der Techniker Krankenkasse? Nein, ich glaube nicht. Ja, aber da kannst du doch genau nachschauen, wann du bei welchem Arzt warst, welche Impfungen du hast, welche Medikamente du hast. Du musst dir um nichts mehr Gedanken machen. Die weiß alles für dich, diese App-Funktion. Das ist wie so eine Krankenakte oder was? Ja, eine digitale Krankenakte in deiner App, in der TK-App, TK Safe.
Und das ist, kostet wie viel?
Mehrere Milliarden Euro.
Das kann ich mir nicht leisten.
Nein, die kostet nix, Stefan.
Was?
Die ist völlig kostenlos.
Ja, Valentin.
Kannst du dir einfach überall runterladen, wo du deine Apps bekommst.
Und in der App gibt es TK Safe.
Dann ist alles dabei, was du brauchst, musst du dir nicht mehr Gedanken machen und deine
Gesundheit ist in guten Händen.
Wenn es auch was für euch ist, dann googelt einfach mal, denn alle weiteren Infos findet ihr einfach bei einer ganz klassischen Onlinesuche nach Teka Safe mit F.
Und jetzt viel Spaß bei der Folge weiterhin und ich wünsche dir alles Gute und gute Besserung. Dankeschön.
Werbung. Ich war nämlich auch bei euch beim Zahnarzt mal wieder, seit langer Zeit, und das ist das Worst-Case-Szenario eingetreten, was ich... Zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben habe ich eine Füllung bekommen. Was wurde gefüllt? Karies wurde gefüllt. So ein schöner Schokokern oder was? Ja. So ein Kaugummikern. So ein Erdbeer kann man da wegcracken. Und dann kann man immer, wenn man bei den Zahn geht, hat man so einen leichten Erdbedbeerfilm. Ja, oder man merkt, oh, ich schmecke schon wieder Erdbeere, meine Füllung ist offen. Oh, geil, das ist eine gute Idee. Geht das raus irgendwann? Klar, alles geht raus. Aber ich war so fasziniert davon. Also erst mal morgens, es war ganz früh morgens, und dann hat er mit Spritzen reingedonnert in beide Seiten, hat dann zwei Füllungen gemacht, also gebohrt. Rezeption. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man da bohrt, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe vorher keine Gedanken gemacht, was es ist genau, was heißt Füllung. Ich dachte, wie man das kennt. Wie so ein Tortenüberzug. Ja, genau. Ja, genau, dieses Spritzgebäck. Tüte, ja. Eine Tüte, ich dachte dann, ich dachte, Karius macht ja schon Löcher. Da stecken die, das ist eine ganz kleine Tüte, stecken die da rein ins Loch und dann drücken die drauf, bis es voll ist, dann wird ein bisschen gebügelt, damit es fest ist und glatt und dann ist es jut. Nein, dann kam man mit dem Bohrer um die Ecke und lachte ich mir, ah, das ist Bohren, klar, ja, verständlicherweise. Das ist das, wenn man damals gesagt hat, putzt eure Zähne, damit kein Karies entsteht, damit nicht gebohrt werden muss. Das ist die Horrorvorstellung, von der ich immer gewarnt wurde. Das ist jetzt genau der Moment. Und dann ging es los, war sehr angenehm, weil man nichts gemerkt hat.
Ich habe immer diesen Moment, ich finde es wahnsinnig unangenehm, beim Zahnarzt zu sitzen, weil ich immer schlucken muss. Du hast immer das Gefühl, es ist zu viel Wasser in meinem Mund, es ist zu viel in meinem Mund gerade, ich muss schlucken. Und du siehst immer den Augen von denen, die ja zwei Zentimeter von deinen Augen entfernt sind. Man kann nichts verstecken. Ich challenge euch auch mal, lasst die Augen auf bei dem ganzen Prozess und guckt denen direkt in die Augen, weil die hängen ja so über dir. Und irgendwann hast du so awkward Augenkontakt mit diesen Leuten, die in deinem Mund sind, mit den beiden Händen und mit zwei Zentimeter vor deinen Augen hängen und du kannst die so nah vor dir, dass du nicht mehr scharf stellen kannst, so nah sind die vor dir. Und irgendwann habt ihr so Augenkontakt, weil er merkt, dass die Augen hängen. Weil meistens, ich weiß, ein Patient macht die Augen so und wartet, bis es vorbei ist. Dieses, ja, du, bringt es einfach hinter mich. Aber lass die Augen mal auf und guck die in die Augen. Und es ist auch lustig irgendwie, wenn die in der Mund vorwerkeln und das dann passiert. Naja, und dann war es irgendwann fertig und ich muss sagen, dann war erst meine Zunge taub für den Rest des Morgens, war es ein bisschen blöd, weil ich hatte ein paar wichtige Skype-Calls an dem Morgen und meine Zunge war taub, ich konnte nicht sprechen.
Es war einfach nur, meine Zunge war nicht zu gebrauchen und das klang sehr blöd dann den ganzen Morgen und irgendwann liest es danach und danach habe ich nichts mehr gespürt. spürt. Also ich habe sehr schnell an dem gleichen Tag abends noch nicht mehr gemerkt, dass ich heute morgen, dass heute morgen meine Zähne durchgebohrt wurden und Keramik reingespritzt wurde. War nicht sehr gut. Und es wurde herausgefunden, dass ich eine Nachtspange brauche, weil ich offensichtlich mit den Zähnen male aus Stress. Ich habe aber gedacht, ich habe natürlich dann diese ganze Schiene und so habe ich jetzt bekommen, aber ich nehme die nicht. Sorry, das ist wie die... Stefan, das muss schon sein. Nee, ich habe dann überlegt, ich meditiere vielleicht abends mal so fünf Minuten oder sowas gegen den Stress. Aber du kannst nicht jedes Problem durch Meditation lösen. Ich weiss, du hast die App, ich weiss, du zahlst 1,99 Monat, aber du kannst nicht jedes Problem durch Meditation lösen. Warum denn nicht ein bisschen meditieren gegen Stress? Und dann habe ich keine Zahlen ich keine Zahlenmahnen mehr. Ja, aber du schläfst doch. Vor Mahlzahlen. Schlaf bringt das was, deinen Stress zu reduzieren? Bist du im Schlaf gestresst? Ungscheinlich. Nee, ich glaube, ich bin vom Tag gestresst und deswegen malen meine Zähne. Musst du an den Traum denken, wie ich letztens hatte. Manchmal wache ich auf und denke mir boah, das war's jetzt oder was? Und zwar habe ich mich mit jemandem unterhalten und die Person meinte so, du, folgendes, wenn du irgendwie nebenbei so ein bisschen was nebenbei verdienen willst, du kannst ja einfach in Moe's Taverne arbeiten. Moe's Taverne von den Simpsons. Und ich weiß noch, wie ich im Traum reagiert habe, so als ja, muss ich halt mal gucken, wie ich das mache, aber ja, danke, danke für den Tipp. Das ist ein Tipp. Warst du denn im Traum gelb? Nee, gar nicht. Wer hat den Tipp gegeben? Überhaupt nicht. Ganz normale Person einfach so, du, wenn du nebenbei bist, was für den, Tipp, du kannst mit Monster Werner arbeiten. Hat ein normaler Dude gesagt. Ja. So ein normaler, der würde auch normaler Pokémon sammeln. Es war eine normale Traumfigur, unkreative Traumfigur. Ja. Und er einfach sagt, oh, so ein Tipp, mit dem man wirklich nichts anfangen kann. Kommt dann im Traum der Cut-To, du bist in der Bar mit diesem Lappen? Nein, es hat geendet in einem, ja, muss ich mal, muss ich ja echt mal gucken, ja, danke. Check ich mal meine Termine, dann habe ich zwei Stunden lang Termine gecheckt und dann war der Traum vorbei. Muss ich mal. Und du hast gesagt, ich habe keinen Fall für diese Arthouse-Scheisse mehr. Gib mir Action, gib mir Michael Bay, ich will fliegen, ich will explodieren, ich will Sex haben, aber stattdessen immer diese awkward Konversation, so dieses, ja, muss ich mal, muss ich echt mal gucken. Ich habe mal so einen richtig geilen Thriller geträumt. Also im Traum war der richtig geil, ich bin aufgestanden, dachte mir, das muss ich verfilmen und da habe ich gemerkt, das hat den Vordergrund keinen Sinn ergeben. Aber der Bösewicht war geil und super angsteinflösend. Im Traum ist man nicht so distanziert, im Traum hat man wirklich Schiss vor dem. Aufgewacht denkt man, wow, der war ein guter Bösewicht. Und zwar war der Bösewicht Javier Bardem. Ah, geil. Aber nicht als der Mensch. Nee, nee, nicht als Javier Bardem mit seinem normalen Street-Outfit, sondern halt in so einem geilen No-Country-For-Old-Man-artigen Bösewicht-Outfit. Und ich fand es halt total geil und dachte mir, ich war morgens plötzlich so dankbar und war so distanziert von meiner Angst, realen Angst im Traum und habe es eher gesehen wie so ein Film, wie so Unterhaltung und habe dann den Impuls gehabt, mich bei Javier Badem für die Performance zu bedanken, weil er in gewisser Weise sein Gesicht hergegeben hat für den Bösewicht in meinem Traum, was ich halt toll fand, weil er hat ja viel zu tun. Aber er war in meinem Traum der Bösewicht. Das war ein Moment zwischen uns beiden, zwischen Javier und mir. Ja, ich muss Ihnen leider sagen, ich glaube, Sie kriegen die Wohnung nicht. Wir haben uns jetzt für jemand anderen entschieden. Wie, wegen meinem Kaffeefleck? War es wegen meinem Kaffeefleck? Nee, Sie erzählen von diesem Javier Badem. Aber es ist tatsächlich auch oft so, mal ein bisschen von der anderen Seite, dass ich auch und auch für uns beide Nachrichten bekomme wie, du bist gestern in meinem Traum aufgetaucht und es ist sehr schwer darauf zu antworten, zu sagen, okay, ja, sorry, gerne geschehen. Ich hoffe, da kann man nichts darauf antworten. Es gibt einfach Dinge, da kann man nichts darauf antworten. Einfach so.
Ja, ähm, jo.
Ich habe hier jemanden in meinem
Englischbuch gesehen, der sieht genauso aus wie
Stefan.
Okay.
Liebe Grüße, Florian.
Ja, muss ich mal schauen.
Das ist so die generelle Antwort.
Ja, muss ich jetzt echt, ja, ja, ja.
Muss ich echt mal gucken. Haha, müssen wir mal gucken. Ja, muss ich echt mal gucken. Ja, ich melde mich dann einfach noch mal. Wir melden uns dann einfach noch mal. Liebe Grüße, Florentin und Stefan. Ja, aber das ist so unangenehm. Ich weiß, weil die Autokorrektur macht oft, wenn ich sage, kommuniziere, dann macht die oft aus Florentin automatisch Florentin Will.
Und es ist ein Unterschied. Ja, es ist ein Unterschied. Es ist ein grosser Unterschied. Grosser Unterschied. Ob, wenn jemand schreibt so, hey, ich mag das Podcast-Ufo und man sagt so, hey, cool, freut mich, vielen Dank, weiterhin viel Spaß, beste Grüße, Florentin Will. Es ist was anderes, als wenn man schreiben würde, liebe Grüße, Florentin. Ja, das war auch eine lustige Situation, weil neulich meine Chefs beide eine Karte unterschreiben mussten. Und dann kam die Assistentin der Chefs vorbei und er hat einfach diese Karte gegeben. Das war eine gute Besserungskarte für eine gute Freundin. Und mein Chef hat nicht gefragt, nicht geguckt, was das für eine Karte ist und war gerade sehr im Stress und hat halt mit Vor- und Nachnamen unterschrieben. Gute Besserung, ein bisschen großer Text und dann Vor- und Nachnamen, Stefan Tietze. Und das ist dann automatisch super unbesichtigt. Dann hat sie gesagt, du kannst dich mit Vor- und Nachnamen unterschreiben. Und er so, oh fuck. Und dann mussten die Karte nochmal neu geschrieben werden. Wir mussten alle nochmal neu unterschreiben. Ja, aber es ist ein großer Unterschied, ob du jetzt mit, äh, ob du mit Liebegrüsse zum Geburtstag, ob du da mit Stefan Tietze doch auf dem Fünster schreibst, oder es ist ein klasserer Stefan. Es ist gar keine Diskussion. Es muss ein Stefan sein. Ja, es muss einer sein. Vielleicht sogar Fanta oder der Steffster oder was auch immer, aber nicht Stefan Tietze. Vielleicht sogar Stefan Herz. Alles Gutes im Geburtstag, Stefan Tietze. Aber es ist vor allem, meine Autokorrektur macht auch manchmal Florentin Wild zusammengeschrieben. Florentin Wild zusammen. Und das ist das Allerabsurdeste. Ja, du machst immer Florentiner bei dir. Ja? Ja, Florentiner. Flötenton kommt auch oft, aber mittlerweile habe ich es halt oft genug geschrieben, dass es Florentin, aber es macht einfach einen großen Unterschied. Wie häufig schreibt man Flötenton als Textnachricht? Ich will gerne mal in der Statistik sehen, wie oft im letzten Jahr das Wort Flötenton geschrieben wurde und wie auch das Wort Florentin geschrieben wurde. Es ist unerklärlich, wie das da vorhanden kann. Das ist ein guter Vergleich, aber es scheint sehr wichtig zu sein. Flötenlobby, diese Flöten-Whatsapp-Gruppen, die machen diese Statistik kaputt. Diese fucking Flöten, ey. Aber wir haben übrigens eine Statistik bekommen, wie viele Taktstöcke verkauft wurden. Wirklich? Ja. Stimmt, das hatten wir angefragt in der letzten Folge. Und wir haben nochmal eine Sendung. Im letzten Jahr waren es, glaube ich, 38, wenn mich nicht mehr in Erinnerung steht. In einem Musikladen, in einem Jahr 38 oder 64. Das sind die beiden Zahlen, die mir gerade einfallen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Beide in ähnliche Höhe. Ich finde es schon bei. Das ist extrem hoch. Ich dachte, drei im Jahr, weil wie viele Dirigenten gibt es denn? Die gehen ja kaputt. Wodurch gehen die kaputt? Wenn du Wagner dirigierst und dann einfach irgendwie mit viel Schwung und dann fliegt es in die Oboe oder was? Ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass ich, das war echt fantastisch. Ich hatte richtig viel Spaß in Bayreuth, ehrlich gesagt. Das Klientel war ein bisschen weird, aber auch interessant, weil es so wahnsinnig divers war. Also, ist weird ein anderes Wort für rechtsradikal oder was versuchst du gerade? Auch aus Burschenschaften mit einem Schlag im Gesicht. Schmiss im Gesicht. Und wo dann so ein Rosshaar reingelegt wurde, damit es entzündet bleibt, damit es diese Narbe schön bildet mit dem Schmiss. Also ganz absurd, solche Menschen. Dann habe ich jemandem die Karte verkauft, der auch ein paar kannte, weil er war ein Journalist und erkannte viele Leute, die dann da in diesem VIP-Bereich saßen, die ich alle nicht kannte. Aber da waren halt teilweise so Besitzer von so riesengroßen deutschen Unternehmen, die man so, es war nicht der, aber so Fischer-Dübel-artig, also die teilweise den reichsten Menschen der Welt gehören, weil die einfach damals diese Idee hatten für Dübel, also diese typisch deutschen Reichen. Ja, so ein Türstopper. Ja, genau. Einfach sämtliche Türstopper auf der Welt. Er hat die Türstopper auf der Welt, er hat von Stopper, Stopper aus Reda-Wiedenbrück und dann hing er da rum und hat halt gehört zu den reichsten Menschen der Welt. Und meine Plätze, meine Plätze waren wirklich bescheuert, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich war, es hat aufgebaut wie so ein großes Amphitheater, gilt ja als eines der besten Opernhäuser der Welt, was die Akustik angeht, das ist ja weltberühmt dafür, Weltkulturerbe und so. Leider saß ich in der Loge hinten. Das sind nicht die besseren Plätze, das klingt halt immer so, oh, auch wieder viele Nachrichten bekommen, danke dafür. Aber es ist nicht besser, weil du den Klang nicht so mitbekommst, weil das davor die Wand ist, die so ein bisschen schluckt einfach. Und ja, deswegen war ich so ein bisschen schade. Ich habe die Meistersinger von Nürnberg gesehen, interessante Oper, die Inszenierung war wahnsinnig kompliziert, von einem Juden. Das war die erste Oper inszeniert von einem Juden in Bayreuth, die dann vor drei Jahren irgendwann eine Premiere hatte. Also, wahnsinnig spannende Inszenierung, ich habe sie nicht hundertprozentig verstanden, ehrlich gesagt, ich musste danach noch viel nachlesen, und die meisten Kritiker haben es auch nicht verstanden, was ich auch ganz beruhigend fand dann. Aber was echt krass war, weil der letzte Akt hat komplett in einem Raum der Nürnberger Prozesse gespielt, in dem Richtsaal. Und irgendwann musste Wagner halt, also eine der Figuren war Wagner selbst, Hans Sachs ist die Figur eigentlich, aber die war verteilt als Richard Wagner, tritt in den Zeugenstand, der Nürnberger Pro Prozesse und singt halt den letzten Song,
den letzten Hit, den letzten Banger.
Und
irgendwann kommt es zum Finale
und plötzlich geht die Rückwand auf
und der Nürnberger Prozessse
fliegt weg, also nach oben, ist ein wahnsinnig
großes Theater mit einer wahnsinnig großen Spielfläche.
Und dann kam ein Orchester
von hinten dran gefahren, ein zweites Orchester
kam von hinten aus dem Off nach vorne gefahren. Wagner hat zum Publikum gesungen, dreht sich um und das Zeugenpult wird zu einem Dirigentenpult und er dirigiert dann halt das grosse Finale der Oper, dirigiert er aus dem Zeugenpult der Nürnberger Prozesse zu Ende. Und hat das zweite Orchester dann auch wirklich gespielt? Nee, nee, nee. Das waren nur Schauspieler. Aber es war halt fantastisch. Das war wirklich so ein cooler Effekt.
Das Finale war wirklich atemberaubend. Und das hat es halt auf den Punkt gebracht irgendwie, worum es ja auch bei ihm geht. Natürlich spielt er total viel rein und so. Und da gibt es ja dieses coole Zitat von Leonard Bernstein, der selber Jude war und gefragt wurde, ob er Wagner hasst. Und er hat gesagt, ich hasse Wagner, aber auf Knien. Und das ist einfach ein sehr schönes Zitat. Und da dachte ich auch in dem Moment, ja, man hasst ihn. Und natürlich, dieser Nürnberger Prozess, Settling hat das halt total verdeutlicht, dass am Ende aber die Musik sprechen sollte. Und das war halt schön, auch von einem jüdischen Regisseur so zu sehen. Das war schon wirklich beeindruckend. Aber jetzt, komm, lass uns mal zur prickelnden Stelle kommen. Hast du Promis gesehen? Nee, keinen Prominenten. Kein Ralf Schmitz, erste Reihe? Wie gesagt, ich habe halt diese so Fischer-Dübel-artige Leute getroffen. Ja, die hinter den Kulissen die Fägen zieht. Die man auch kennt, aber ich habe keinen wirklich Prominenten getroffen. Keinen? Nee, null.
Kein Markus Merrier profitlich?
Niemand.
Gar nichts.
Ich wurde erkannt einmal, lustigerweise, von jemandem, der Statist war abends.
Das ist dein Klientel.
Das ist deine Zielgruppe. Ein großer Podcast-Sufa-Fan war abends da.
Du, wir lieben Statisten.
Ja.
Wir treten ja immer in die Bresche.
Sagt man das so?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heute funktioniert.
Jedenfalls, wir werfen uns in die Bresche für Statisten auf den deutschen Bühnen.
Wir machen direkt mal weiter.
Wir haben heute eine Picke-Packe-Forge.
Folge, Folge.
Und zwar hat uns jemand geschrieben, wir haben letzte Woche, beziehungsweise vor zwei Wochen, ja drüber gesprochen zum Thema Kreuzfahrt. Ja, wir haben darüber geredet und wir haben gefragt, wie das ist mit Mann über Bord, Frau über Bord, was passiert da, wie oft passiert das denn, dass Leute während der Kreuzfahrt über Bord fallen, muss man dann umdrehen, werden die gerettet, wie funktioniert das eigentlich alles? Und mir hat jemand geschrieben, der anscheinend auf einem Kreuzfahrtschiff arbeitet, wie das alles funktioniert.
Und vielen Dank dafür, wir hören mal rein, was er zu berichten hat in unserem Podcast-UFO-Reality-Check. Der Das Podcast-UFO-Reality-Check. Jo, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt ankommt oder direkt im Spam landet, aber ich habe aktuelle
Folge meinen Beileid gehört und ich arbeite momentan auf einem Kreuzfahrtschiff und dann dachte ich, kann ich euch direkt mal eine Einreichung schicken, weil tatsächlich viel gesoffen und es gehen nicht so viele Leute über Bord. Ich glaube, waren das so die zwei Hauptdinge.
In Verbindung gab es aber schon mal einen Vorfall, den ich mitbekommen habe, dass...
Wann hat ihr das erzählt? Jetzt bin ich mir ganz unsicher.
Jedenfalls gab es mal ein Kommandoman über Bord, was auf Schiffsprache Oscar heißt.
Oscar, Oscar, Oscar ist der Geheimcode der Seefahrer auf Kreuzhafschiffen, falls jemand über Bord geht. Und ja, jedenfalls wurde dann angehalten und alles abgesucht und dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass zwei besoffene Leute eine Liege über Bord geworfen haben. Das war aber zu Ende. Vielen Dank. Nee, ich mal das Ende. Das war zu Ende. Vielen Dank für deine Einsendung. Finde ich ganz fantastisch, dass es da anscheinend noch so Geheimcodes gibt. So ähnlich wie bei uns in der Schule gab es dann auch so Geheimcodes für Amokläufer und so, damit nicht alle in Panik ausbrechen. Was ich besonders nicht verstehe, weil jeder den Code kannte. Koma. Bei uns war es immer, Bibi Blocksberg ist in der Schule. Und es war immer so ein Code so stellvertretend, so Bibi Blocksberg ist jetzt in der Sporthalle. Wo auch der Amokläufer sagt. Sowohl der Amokläufer als auch sämtliche potenziellen Opfer kennen Code und wissen, was es bedeutet. Das ist ein großes Problem. Vielleicht ist es aber trotzdem psychologisch was anderes. Haben die bei euch auch die, wo man sagt, das sind die potenziellen Amokläufer, hatten die nicht auch zufällig frei an dem Tag bei euch? Ja, ja, klar. Es war auch schon ein bisschen so, und natürlich rücken alle so ein Stück weg von den potenziellen Leuten. Alle mit Ramstein und Marilyn Manson-Shirt waren noch an dem Tag nicht in der Schule, komischerweise. Die ganzen Counter-Strike-Spieler. Und ja, vielen Dank für diese Einsendung, sehr interessant, Oscar. Ich finde solche Sprache nachher super, vor allem wenn sie enden mit, man hat sich herausgestellt, dass es nur eine Lige war und Ende. Und man sagt, ja, hä, ich war gerade so in einem Setting drin, ich habe mich gerade so wohlgefühlt auf eurem Schiff. Aber ich frage mich, wann sie das rausgefunden haben, ob sie dann nicht irgendwie so, ja, irgendwie heldenhaft springt der Kapitän ins Wasser und irgendwie so ein Rettungsring wird geworfen und dann fischen die einfach so eine Lige raus. Man wirft ja direkt Dinge hinterher, über Bord, damit man Flaschen, damit du das wiederfindest, die Stelle an die Strömung. Du wirfst sofort was hinterher. Zur Not dein Kind. Zur Not das Kind. Muss sich halt dann jemand opfern. Ja mein Gott. Muss sein. Die Liegen sind nicht billig. Die kosten 100 Euro pro Stück. Ich hätte gesagt, es ist deutlich häufiger passiert, ehrlich gesagt. Soll die über Bord fallen? Ja. Aber die haben ja verschiedene Stockwerke, oder? Ich glaube, wenn du irgendwo über die Religen gehst, dann fällst du einfach auf das nächste Deck. Das ist übrigens das Podcast-UFO-Nachtrag. Bei dem Baby, was, genau, Triggerwarnung, jetzt hat es ja genug Zeit, um auszuschalten, das Baby, was über Bord gegangen ist, ist auch nicht ins Wasser gefallen. So viel zu unserem lustigen Wassermann-Bit. Es ist einfach nur aufs untere Decke knallt. Aber auch hinüber, oder? Er lebt jetzt als Deckmann. Nein, ist tot. Hat er dadurch Leidenschaft für die Seefahrt gefunden. Ist aufs Trambolindeckck gefallen. Man ist jetzt ein richtiger Seebär geworden. Nee, ist tot. Nicht unterwegs. Nee, ist mausetot. Aber dafür hat unser, der der Flying-Flyboard-Typ, die... Ah ja, Schlagzeilen gemacht! Der die ganze Armee ist, die ganze französische Flyboard-Armee, ist der Frank Zapata oder wie der heißt, Frank Zappa, der jetzt über den Ärmelkanal geflogen ist. Er hat es geschafft, aber wirklich in einem atemberaubenden Tempo, was einem Angst macht, weil er sieht einfach total gruselig aus, mit dieser Waffe in der Hand und diesem Board, was so Silversurfer-mäßig einfach unglaublich schnell ist. Der hat aber eine große Reichweite, ne, also der ist ein gutes Stück gekommen. Ja, ja, ist abgefahren. Ich frage mich wirklich, wann kommt das raus? Das wird mein neues Boosted-Board auf jeden Fall.
Kriegt er nicht auch so Angebote, irgendwie so, ja, hier, wir sind die rumänische Armee, hättest du mal Bock, irgendwie für uns zu arbeiten, so für einen Monat oder so? Oder der ist ja nicht Teil eines stehenden Heeres, oder der ist ja ein Privattyp. Ich weiß nicht. Oder es gehört ja zur französischen Armee. Er wurde ja vorgestellt als Teil der französischen Armee. Ich dachte ja, okay, krass, wenn jetzt so 50 Leute von denen da oben dann Amokläufer abknallen oder Terroristen. Holy shit, ich würde in Frankreich keinen Terrorakt mehr durchführen, aber es hat einer. Der ist jetzt halt wirklich so eine Art moderner Batman. Wenn irgendwas passiert, ruft jeder den an, ich bin in zwei Stunden da, und dann fliegt er los. Abgestürzt, sorry, ist schon wieder passiert. Leider nicht genug Sprit gehabt.
Akku ist gerade leer. Kann passieren,
aber er ist wirklich eine Art Modern Iron Man.
Aber er hat jetzt halt auch die Macht, alleine
die ganze Armee zu übernehmen.
Weil wenn du zu viel Macht einer einzigen Person
gibst, dann kann er sagen, warum soll ich für euch kämpfen.
Mir gehört es Frankreich. Gegen euch. Ich bin jetzt Frankreich.
Ich bin jetzt Frankreich.
Je suis la France.
Und dann sagen alle, nicht schon wieder.
So ein Scheiss. Wir hatten so lange Ruhe, so lange Ruhe. Wir haben aber auch Pech. Ja, na ja, genau. Es geht immer wieder von vorne los. Ein bisschen viel Macht. Aber vielen Dank für die Einsendung. Finde ich eine tolle Form, das soll uns die Sprachnachrichten schicken. Ja, tolle Videos auch, vielen Dank dafür. Vielen Dank. Und ja, schön, dass ihr da seid. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Liebe Hörer. Ja, ansonsten, ich war jedenfalls sehr zufrieden mit meiner Urlaubszeit. Das Boot war ganz toll. Ich merke auch, dass Menschen auf Wasser freundlicher sind. Ja, weil sie müssen freundlich sein, weil man kann nicht weglaufen. Genau, aber auch die, man begegnet an anderen Schiffen, wir waren halt in Berlin, auf einem See, was fantastisch ist. Berlin ist ja wirklich eine ganz, ganz schöne Stadt, weil da gibt es so viele Seen drumherum. Es ist ja einer der wasserreichsten Städte Europas, muss man ja auch mal ehrlich sagen. Vielleicht auch nicht Europas, vielleicht Deutschlands. Ich hätte Panik auf dem Boot, also gar nicht wegen Boot und Runterfallen, sondern einfach soziale Panik. Weil ich bin dann am entspanntesten sozialen Situationen, wenn ich jede Sekunde gehen kann. Deswegen auch immer im Club Jacke anbehalten, immer direkt Mütze aufbehalten, damit jeder weiß, oh, der ist nur auf dem Sprung, der ist sofort wieder weg. Deswegen Tipp, Badehose an und jederzeit, wenn das Gespräch abäppt, einfach ins Wasser fallen lassen. Bisher eigentlich noch mit Monika zusammen und Körper und weg. Einfach direkt weg. Deswegen habe ich da...
Weil alle direkt auch die Stimmung von Smalltalk in Richtung
Wow!
Ja, wow!
Nach dem Salto!
Ja, genau, es ist sofort Badespaß.
Du kannst ja auch das Gespräch lenken in die Richtung.
Total.
Einfach ins Salto ins Wasser machen, alle Wow!
Du, eine Arschbombe beendet jedes unangenehme Thema.
Jedes Gespräch.
Immer.
Das ist einfach direkt an.
Vielleicht hat deine Mutter Krebs oder Wow! Sammelaffelzeite! Wow, Klatsche! Ja. Nee, aber auch so andere Bote, die einem gegenkommen, sind alle freundlich. Und man winkt, auf Wasser winkt man. Ich weiß nicht, was es in den Menschen ist, was sobald du den Aggregatzustand fest unter deinem Boden verlässt und auf flüssig gehst, winkt man.
Winken ist ultimativ.
Oder halt Nebelhorn.
So ein ganz intensives Neen.
Unangenehm.
Ist perfekt.
Aber es ist auch super spannend.
Ich finde ja auch diese ganze Schiffsdynamik mit Meuterei und so total spannend, weil du auf so einem Schiff, selbst wenn du der König bist oder so ein hoher Offizier oder Admiral, dann hast du ja, du kannst ja nicht unendlich viele Leute anzubefehlen, die dir helfen würden, sondern du bist halt hundert Leute auf so einem Schiff und wenn du sie mit der Mannschaft verscherzt, dann essen die dich auf. Du kannst nichts dagegen tun. Du hast keine Burg, in der du dich verschanzen kannst, du hast nicht irgendwie Kanonen, das war es halt dann einfach. Keine Güte. Deswegen ist es immer super interessant. Kann es abschießen. Ja gut, aber es stimmt schon, es ist eine unangenehme Situation, du kommst nicht weg. Ich habe zum Beispiel letztens eine Doku gesehen, bald ist ja wieder, du wirst es wahrscheinlich an mir erleben, in zwei Wochen ist wieder grösste Dota-Turnier der Welt, die International.
Und es ist immer eine heiße Zeit.
Und letztes Jahr hat ja mein Lieblingsteam OG
gewonnen. Und die haben jetzt nochmal...
Deutsche, ne? Ne, die haben jetzt nochmal...
Doch, die wohnen in Köln.
Ne, die haben jetzt nochmal
dieses Jahr nochmal eine Doku rausgebracht,
um den ganzen Werdegang, und das ist ja eine unglaublich dramatische Geschichte.
Ja, genau, jetzt mal erzählt. Mit Verrat und
ist ja geil. Und die haben dann auch wirklich
dir dann immer erzählt, wie das war damals.
Und dann gab es immer so Schnittbilder,
Aber den ganzen Werdegang und das ist ja eine unglaublich dramatische Geschichte. Ja, genau, jetzt mal erzählt. Mit Verrat und ist ja egal. Und die haben dann auch wirklich dir dann immer erzählt, wie das war damals und dann gab es immer so Schnittbilder, wie die in ihrem Alltag jetzt verfolgt werden. Und dann halt so, was machen sie jetzt so und dann keine Ahnung. Und dann gab es eine, ein Segment mit einem Spieler, Arna heißt der, und der wurde in einem Heissluftballon gefilmt. Und es waren aber nur Schnittbilder, es wurde nie gesprochen in diesen Aufnahmen und ich konnte mir das nicht anschauen,
weil ich mir immer denken musste, wie
extrem unangenehm muss dieser Dreh
gewesen sein, dass der einfach, weil das
ist dann so, ah, wir wollen dich in deinem normalen
Familienalltag filmen, wir filmen dich
einfach. Und dann kommt halt, da hast du einen Kameramann,
Redakteur, irgendwie noch einen Tonmann
und dann steht der einfach mit seiner Mutter
dann in diesem Heissluftballon, fliegt hoch und du hast ja nach drei Sekunden genug Material. Nach drei Sekunden hast du genug Schnittbilder. Du zeigst ihm, wie er aus dem Korb guckt und du zeigst ihm, wie er mit seiner Mutter redet. That's it. Und dann kannst du die Kamera eigentlich ausmachen an dem Punkt und du fliegst aber noch eine Stunde hoch und runter. Against the Arts heißt die Doku. Geil, habe ich lustig drauf. Wo kann man die gucken? Auf YouTube, ist eine tolle Geschichte, aber ich musste das wirklich skippen, das sind Momente, wo ich das nicht ertragen kann. Aber auch weil du halt die hinter den Kulissen kennst und so weiter. Vor allem diese E-Sportler, das sind ja alles mehr oder weniger awkward Leute, also es gibt schon coolere und uncoolere, aber die sind, aber die sind alle im Durchschnitt, sind die alle
eher socially awkward, was man auch
mehr merkt in den Interviews und das ist ja auch immer so das
Problem, wenn ihr so Fussballer eine Weltmeisterschaft
gewinnen, dann rasten die aus
und feiern und jubeln und machen Salte
und so. Aber es sind auch Leute mit Lamborghinis in der Garage.
Richtig und die, sag ich mal,
diese Sportarten haben ja auch eine Show-Tradition.
Also wenn du ein Kind bist
und Fussballer anschaust, dann sind deine Vorbilder, freuen sich und rasten aus und so. Und bei E-Sport gibt es das nicht. Das ist ja nicht existent, noch nicht. Genau, und das heißt, es ist oft so, dass irgendwie ein riesiges Turnier mit mehreren Millionen Euro Preisgeld und so und ein Team nach einem harten Kampf gewinnt und du hast Feuerwerk und Konfetti fliegen und die kommen raus mit den Händen in den Hosentaschen. Ja, der eine ist am Handy schon wieder und zu der Mom. Ja genau und dann so und dann auch hast du dann die Leute, die immer sagen, und jetzt nimm den Pokal, so auf geht's. Ach so, ja, okay, den Pokal, ja. Und dann ja so und dann einfach gar nichts. Und es ist wirklich, wo man sich denkt, Leute! Auch das Doku-Team so, what the fuck. Aber bei OG war es sehr emotional, aber schaut sich an und jetzt in zwei Wochen geht es wieder weiter. Während der Gamescom, dann bin ich ja hier in der Gamescom. Ach ja. Kein Zufall, das allererste TI war ja während der Gamescom. Danach wurde es losgelöst, aber es ist immer noch die gleiche Zeit. Das heißt Games, Games, Games die ganze Woche. Ja, ich freue mich, vielleicht schau ich auch wieder vorbei. Wirklich? Die Rocket Beans machen ja eine coole Feier jedes Jahr. Vielleicht komme ich vorbei. Ja. Das war es von uns, wir müssen leider Schluss machen, aber wir machen jetzt eine kleine zweiwöchige Sommerpause, das heißt nicht auf nächste Woche freuen, denn es geht erst in drei Wochen dann weiter. Wir tanken ein bisschen die Akkus auf, legen uns ein bisschen in die Sonne und überlegen uns neue lustige Dinge, die wir erzählen können, weil wir wissen nichts mehr. Wir haben uns alles gesagt einmal, Florian und ich jetzt, jetzt müssen wir uns mal wieder ein bisschen... Wir fangen wieder von vorne an. Wir fahren ja von an. Wir entspannen ein bisschen, kommen runter und danach machen wir wieder entspannt weiter, weil es immer so Urlaubterminlich immer so ein bisschen schwierig ist. Und von daher viel Spaß und vielleicht sehen wir uns auf der Gamescom oder anderswo, lieben Gruß an die Telegram-Gruppe auch, die sich dieses, die haben sich ihr erstes Real-Life-Treffen tatsächlich. Vielen Dank für das Bild, fand ich echt fantastisch, sehr süss, alle haben sich getroffen.
Ja, sehr großartig auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, da findet ihr Freunde fürs Leben in der Podcast-UFO-Telegram-Gruppe, schaut mal vorbei.
Genau, vielen Dank für die Sprachnachricht an den AIDA-Caption.
Danke an Stefan.
Danke an Florentin und danke an Max fürs Intro.
Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Und heben ab.
Ja, heben ab, klar.